- This pig probably had a family--
- Shh.
- With feelings.
- [Woman with Purple Hair] Stop.
(upbeat music)
- Here's the thing, I come
from a Chinese background.
We literally try to eat
every bit of the animal
so I'm pretty used to this.
- I wonder how many boogers
are in this burrito.
- It looks crazy.
- It looks like regular meat.
- What kind of meat you be eatin'?
- Mm.
It tastes like fat.
- Although you can see like the hairs.
- It's a little hairy.
- That's like when I haven't
shaved for two weeks.
- It's a lot softer than I expected.
- It's very tender.
- I don't know if it's
like the oil from the pig
or it's the oil like they added on later,
but it's very greasy.
- It's just super gelatinous.
Like it just feels like
you're biting into fat.
- It's so squishy.
- The texture and the sliminess
makes me think of snot.
- This is snot.
Y'all, this isn't oil, oil
doesn't stretch like that.
- Something about it, it's
just messin' with my mind.
- I just can't get over the fact that
it came from a little piggy.
- You're eating Fred and George and Porky.
- I think it's important to eat
other parts of the animal.
Otherwise it just goes to waste.
- It's weird that people
have like certain parts
of animals that they feel are more
like "justifiable" to eat.
- There's a lot more to the
animal that goes to waste.
- I love the idea of
using the entire animal.
- At least that way you're kind of
respecting the whole life.
- If you're gonna kill an animal,
you might as well utilize all of it.
- Oh, I was gonna eat that.
What is it?
Should we open it up?
- Bum, bum, bum, bum!
(gasping and laughing)
(yelling)
- That's a pig nose!
- I'm gonna cry.
(laughing)
- Oh yeah.
Oh boy.